for one weekend only we are taking over
10 comedy clubs across the country for
one major comedy event it's gonna
feature great stand-up comics at all 10
clubs simultaneously during the weekend
of October 3rd through the 5th we're
calling it team cocoa house and for more
information tickets
check out team koco.com slash house to
get your tickets we've got a ton of
amazing comics booked for Team Coco
house Deon Cole bill burr TIG Notaro
Pete Holmes
Lori Kilmartin many many more great
lineup now a lot of comedians auditioned
to be part of this team Coco house we've
been working on it for a while and they
all wanted to be part of this weekend so
we had auditions unfortunately we have
pretty high standards and we had to
reject quite a few of the people that
tried out yeah that was no fun at all
yeah it was it was it was tough it's
tough to tell people know your dreams
not coming true and I felt bad about all
the comedians we had to turn down so I
invited a few of them on tonight to do
their sets for you to sort of make up
for it so here a few acts you will not I
repeat not see at the upcoming Team Coco
house shows last gentlemen first act
hails from my hometown of Boston
Massachusetts please welcome please
welcome the man who the Boston Herald
voted 'most Bostonian comic of 2019
Tommy O'Connor
Oh got it so we can piss up in there
feel like a miracle at the Harvest
Festival you know I mean here on the
Warner Brothers lot of the I can smell
the LA River from yeah oh yeah someone
left there bring it out on the roof of
her car yeah I grew up in Boston and I
didn't get any of that a single word I'm
gonna go see a horror movie about the
aurora borealis my brother John wicked
pissah lobster good night Tommy O'Connor
right next up an act who describes
himself as the thinking man's thinking
man please welcome
Socrates palindrome you ever notice well
what else I'm not a contrarian is
exactly what a contrarian would say what
else
to us it's a farmer milking a cow to the
cow it's a molester
[Music]
yeah Socrates palindrome just to
reiterate these acts will not be a team
cocoa house finally lots of female
stand-up comedians have performed while
pregnant yeah you probably read about
that in the news but this one takes it
even further she's actually in labor
right now please welcome Terry Parsons
[Music]
as you can see I'm going into labor
labor I get out of the comedy to get
away from that this little guys moving
out today though in this economy
he'll probably move back it in a few
months thank you I'm trying to enjoy it
because this might be the love
[Applause]
Terry Parsons everybody that's it
once again they will not not be joining
us the weekend of October 3rd through
the 5th check out team koco.com slash
house for more details amazing show
tonight from broad city Barry and the
NBC series the good place we love her
Darcy Cardin 0
[Applause]